it was officers inside this Derby police
station who spotted a man with a knife
in their car park
armed officers arrived and around eight
minutes after the incident began the man
was shot
during the incident a window was smashed
at the police station
armed officers were sent to the scene
and a police firearm was then discharged
the male's identity is currently unknown
but I can't confirm he is a white man
and we are working to establish who he
is
the man was given first aid by officers
until paramedics arrived he was taken to
hospital by ambulance but died no one
else was injured
people who were in this street heard
police shouting at the man to put his
weapon down and then multiple gunshots
each officer who was there at that
moment will be expected to give a full
account of exactly what happened
Mark Baxter Works nearby
the heads the gunshots uh five indep in
individual gunshots I could see a police
officer
um on response like you say on telly
really you know
um young guy in all the flat jackets and
stuff just just pointed down and gone on
the floor
officers have given their initial
accounts to investigators from the
police Watchdog The iopc Who described
the incident as tragic they confirmed
that a knife had been found and said a
detailed independent inquiry is underway
Lita Dowd Sky News Derby